I want to pull up this tweet that I just
saw this is from uh Jeremy Frankl for
anyone in Texas media he says Hilton
Hotels will be hosting a conference for
Hamas supporters in Houston organizes in
the US campaign for Palestinian rights
notoriously proud Jew haters Rashida Tay
Linda sarur Mark Lamont Hill and several
others he says call hon Hilton holtels
to voice your objection remind them
they're breaking their own policy they
say in compliance with the Patriot Act
as well as International anti-terrorism
rules Hilton does not support
organizations that engage in Terrorist
AC activities or in involved in any acts
dangerous to human life that are a
violation of the criminal laws of any
country where we operate uh I'm just
going to outright say Don't call Hilton
Hotels and complain about leftists
having their conference that's not a
good idea and I'll explain exactly why I
would like to see all the videos of
Rashida T at a pro Hamas rally
explaining why she supports terrorism so
that I can show my liberal family
members and say see that's the
importance of free speech so to see
conservatives be like how dare they
support this we must cite the Patriot
Act to get them banned no no no no no no
no no I am I am tired of going to a
liberal and being like did you know that
rash rashita T said X prove it I'm like
well I can't find it because they censor
it no no no I want just like when the
DSA had that meeting where they were
like yelling about pronouns and
everyone's screaming over clapping I
want those videos to exist please don't
don't get this event canel well you know
what happened that we had um you know
the world professional association for
transgender Health they had a meeting in
all like last year or something and we
had a reporter undercover at that
meeting um who was you know streaming
the videos cuz they had streaming but
only if you had like registered and
whatever streaming the videos and all of
that stuff and when we published a bunch
of those videos and when we wrote down
with no analysis just exactly the things
that these people said about how unic
should be a gender identity for children
and how the chapter on how children can
identify as Unix had a lot of research
gathered from a child porn website about
Unix right like this is what they were
talking about um the people who we
quoted who gave their talk at w paath
with pride and joy um and inclusivity
they came after us with a legal letter
saying like you can't write down and
publish what we said and we're like but
you you said it though this is why lives
of Tik Tok get in trouble you did say it
and we're going to publish it you're
just showing what they said they hate
themselves though because it's all a
projection not to make light of any of
this but you mentioning Patriot Act and
do you think somebody like wrote Into
the patriot act like why don't we ban
terrorism conferences
like the terrorists try to have
conferences but the the idea that having
a conference in support of Palestine cuz
they're not saying literally Hamas but
we know it kind of is but like either
way a group of people gathering at a at
a hotel for a conference is a First
Amendment protected activity that's the
right to Peaceable assembly now saying
that you want people to call them call
the Hilton and get them banned is not
government encroachment on speech it's
still just a bad strategy we we want all
the videos in the world of these people
being anti-semitic so that it will be
without a doubt then when when it comes
to the 2024 elections you can play these
videos on Loop you know what you do you
take the videos of them speaking and you
run them as ads on Facebook then you're
going to have your liberal Aunt being
like what's this video of Rashid oh my
what she's saying what and you'll be
like oh I didn't know she hated the Jews
they'll say it was AI wasn't really her
but I mean then fine make that the
battle the point is let them say it yep
yeah I mean think about the classic case
right remember there was this Nazi
organization ACLU defended them so they
could so they could have their March
down the street SK and and yeah exactly
SK Illinois and ski Illinois and it was
shocking for the American people
shocking and it's awful but people saw
that and were like this is wrong it's
terrible and they had an informed
decision about their kind of moral
judgment about these issues which is
which is good that's a good thing yep no
idea should be suppressed I want to hear
everything yeah I I agree and I think
that the American people are smart
enough to be Discerning and figure
things out for themselves I hope so
especially if maybe we do you know that
would be nice it would help things out
maybe a little bit yeah um I agree
though I don't think that should be
suppressing speech I think that people
should gather they have the the right to
gather yeah and do that and the other
thing too is as soon as you start taking
away people's rights you know as they're
enshrined in the Bill of Rights then
they start coming for yours we had a
situation recently Andy no who's with
post-millennial he was giving a speech
he was giving a talk in Richmond and uh
a bunch of activists didn't want him to
speak because he exposes activists for
you know being pretty awful so they
didn't want him to speak they kept
calling everywhere that his talk got
scheduled to get it cancelled and the
Marriot Hotel where it was finally
scheduled to speak canceled his talk you
know and they had to find another
location so I don't see any reason to
get people's talks cancelled no matter
what they're talking about right yeah
and it also forces people to meet and
discuss these things
underground which then generally leads
to pretty dangerous activity right right
right when when I was teaching uh
journalism fiction all this stuff I
wanted the students to be uh to
experience ideas outside of their
typical you know worldview right because
I would tell them you need to uh let
your the immune system of your ideas
build up because if they don't
experience these ideas these horrible
ideas and when they do encounter them in
the real world they'll just collapse
their immune system will die right you
have to know how you feel about these
bad ideas you know tweak your ideas here
and there but if you keep suppressing
stuff yeah they'll just fester in the
dark and come back yeah and you see so
much of this right ster sterilization of
history so under the Obama
Administration they said we're going to
remove the Confederate flags at
Gettysburg and it's like people aren't
there maybe somebody is but generally
people aren't there to celebrate the
Confederate flags it's actually
something did happen there a historical
event that literally set the course of
this country yeah it's kind of important
for people to understand and know what
took place there right and if you're not
confronted with that those ideas and
what the Confederacy stood for and what
it was doing and why this war happened
and what it looked
like young people get confronted with
this later in life and it's as you're
saying it just it falls away that
immunization that you said that they
need to have yep well because you need
to know how to defend your ideas you
need to know how to argue the best
points of your opposition just in order
to you know secure your own ideas and
make your own arguments as cohesive as
possible yes yeah you don't know what
you think until you start arguing with
someone who disagrees with you or
reading text that counters your view um
you just don't know exactly and look if
there's for some people the imagery of
the Confederate flag I'm sure is highly
offensive maybe it you know makes them
feel terrible when they see it it's not
most supposed to make you feel good
right um you're supposed to be
confronted with these things so you know
how to respond to it and form opinions
about it and things like that I mean
this is if you go down the rabbit hole
of everything that offends me then we
have to take off the table and everyone
gets a vote on that then what are you
left with right not very much no no
history's been flattened you know I grew
up uh outside of West Point uh the
military academy and um we have the
shell of the atom bomb in the museum and
every summer we have like thousands of
Japanese coming to visit the the bomb
and they take pictures with it and it's
like they're going to witness something
truly horrific right right and uh if you
keep getting rid of these things you
won't feel it like the way you're
talking about you know when I walk
battlefields and you like antium and
you're like 20,000 guys died there you
feel like this crazy History of Violence
that happened there and that's you know
pretty much everywhere in this in this
country well it' be like if you went to
Normandy obviously Germans died there
there is a section for them my
grandfather fought in uh World War II he
got shot in the face in Germany and I'm
sure there I I know there are there
gravestones that have swastikas on them
right now I I think we need to see that
we need to know that that happen right I
it's not that I obviously don't support
the swastika right but this is a
horrific thing that happened in human
history and for us to be able to
confront it and learn from it yeah
that's the thing that I think is like
loss upon the younger generation is that
like you and even my generation the
Millennials is kind of where it started
but you have to understand history to to
understand history you have to know
where you came from other you're going
to make the same mistakes like that
common adage goes if you don't remember
history you don't know history you're
doomed to make their mistakes or like if
you it's just it's just a thing that
everyone I think should know but I'm
shocked at how people actually know that
you go and see these things it's not
comfortable sure all these things in
history are not comfortable and if you
want to talk about them then you have to
be willing to to face it you know what I
mean you can't just run away from
everything and hide it and say oh this
doesn't make me feel good too bad not
everything makes you feel good why a lot
of people have like a very black and
white view of History too you know like
you look at the Civil Wars like you may
understand Sherman as the hero for the
total war but if you really look at what
Sherman did there's a lot of crazy
things he did pretty bad stuff I
consider him our first atom bomb you
know the way he went down and like
destroyed everything and uh you know
there were people work there were
soldiers under him who massacred freed
slaves cuz they were upset they were
following them while they were doing the
trail uh you know the march of the sea
right yeah so it's nothing's easy but
you got to understand that nothing's
easy you know it can't just be flattened
and condensed into this very simple
history it's going to and that's a great
point is is that it's it's not black and
white it's complex right and human
interaction is particularly War it is
complex MH and there's lots of different
interest motivations and all these other
things that happen terrible things on
both sides right I mean and I'm quoting
the guy uh mcamera who happened to be
involved with um the firebombing with
lame in Japan he said had we lost we
would have been deemed and we were
acting as war criminals yeah true and
and that's that's mcera saying that
right and but it was a total war right
they were trying to inflict Total War on
us and we inflicted Total War on them
and then same for Sherman you know he
said war is hell and like people the
idea of hell has been watered down but
legit hell I saw a good quote it said
war is not hell war is war and hell is
hell because in hell everyone who's
there is is guilty everyone there
deserves it and in war everyone there is
innocent yeah exactly
yeah that is fair so war is worse than
hell in there a lot of way let's tell
Sherman that let's dig up William Tuma I
Sherman was kind of a bad guy oh he was
a miserable man he didn't like black
people he he he wanted to destroy the
South he fetishized VI mercilessly
merciless that was brutal yeah it's CRA
so I I I just looked it up I think even
the postm has it yeah they set fire to
the US Embassy in in Beirut the US
Embassy US Embassy yeah numerous tweets
saying the US embassy's been uh fire in
Iraq they're outside the US Embassy
chanting America's the greatest evil the
post millennial tweeting Hezbollah
supporters set fire outside US Embassy
in Beirut I've seen some tweets that
they've pulled the flag the US flag down
or play with the Palestinian flag a lot
of this is hard to confirm I'm just
seeing a lot of it I mean there's
there's a video it's all Breaking right
now yeah this is all Breaking right now
breing right now oh my god when I got in
the I'm getting like phone calls from
one of my writers like what's up I'm
like I can talk to you soon God I I hope
they get our people out of there oh for
sure I'm praying they get our folks out
of there um out of the embassy out of
the
well why do you think they haven't
evacuated them so far just from
precedent set is there like is there an
issue where there's like um is there
like an intelligence failure here where
we just had no idea that this was going
to happen how did we not know that this
was going to happen we saw that was um
being talked about in Israel and people
were criticizing
Netanyahu um for you know having this
had happen you had what is it shinb I
think Shin shinb had taken
responsibility for the failure of you
know just not knowing that this was
going to happen there was some talk that
they knew within a few hours that maybe
something was happening and they didn't
follow it up didn't you say there was a
report that was pulled like a week ago
about getting out of the embassy yeah so
last was it La it must have been last
week time has no meaning um but it must
have been last week um and I was looking
at reporting and you saw on Twitter
there were like maps of like uh
Hezbollah shooting lots of rockets into
Northern Israel a lot of people are
posting this map a lot of people who's
reporting I usually am like oh well if
they have it I'm going to start there
and then dig from there um and it turned
out to be fake I went to the AP and I
was like okay the AP has it maybe we can
maybe we can run a story about how this
is happening as soon as I finished
writing the story and I we were about to
publish it it was like ready to go I
checked back at the AP and their
reporting on it was gone and the maps
turned out to be fake and it just wasn't
real and they were saying that they the
uh us MC in Beirut had been evacuated
and it wasn't thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net